[Música]
la princesa sa sabitri del reino madra
era tan benevolente brillante y radiante
como el Dios sol por el cual fue
nombrada su gracia era conocida en toda
la tierra muchos príncipes poderosos y
mercaderes ricos acudían al palacio de
la familia para pedir su mano en
matrimonio pero al ver su brillante
esplendor en persona los hombres dían su
valentía poco impresionada con esos
pretendientes la princesa decidió
encontrar a un esposo por su
cuenta montada en su carroza dorada
atravesó desiert sin fin brillantes
ciudades y montañas nevadas y rechazó a
muchos hombres a lo largo del
camino finalmente savitri se aventuró en
las profundidades de la jungla donde
encontró a un hombre joven cortando
madera su nombre era
Y amaba la tranquilidad del Bosque tanto
como ella pero la princesa se percató de
que él no estaba en paz después de
hablar durante horas saavan le habló de
su sufrimiento sus padres una vez fueron
ricos gobernantes hasta que su padre
perdió la vista y lo derrocaron en un
violento golpe entonces saavan trabajaba
sin descanso para mantener su nueva vida
sin dinero su determinación y devoción
conmovieron a la
princesa mirarse el uno al otro ella
supo que por fin había encontrado a un
igual savitri corrió a casa a darle a su
padre las buenas noticias pero lo
encontró hablando con narad un viajero
sabio y el mejor Mensajero de los
dioses al principio su padre estaba
feliz de enterarse de saavan pero narad
reveló una Trágica profecía su prometido
tenía un año de
vida savitri quedó
helada había esperado tanto para
encontrar a su compañero estaba
destinada a perderlo la princesa no
aceptaría esos términos juró ante narad
su familia y ante el mismo suria que
nunca se casaría con otro
saavan era el amor de su vida y sus
destinos estaban entrelazados para
siempre conmovido por estas poderosas
palabras el sabio le dijo a la princesa
que siguiera un viejo régimen espiritual
con rezos regulares periodos de ayuno y
la preparación de hierbas y plantas
especiales tal vez podría prolongar la
vida de
saavan tras una boda sencilla la pareja
volvió a la jungla para vivir siguiendo
las instrucciones del sabio esta Modesta
existencia estaba muy lejos de su lujosa
crianza pero eran felices con la
compañía del otro pasó un año y el
esperado día
llegó en su primera aniversario el sol
estaba terriblemente caliente y la
frente de saavan comenzó a arder sabitri
apenas pudo arrastrarlo a la sombra
antes de que se pusiera tieso y frío con
los ojos llenos de Lágrimas vio una
figura inmensa en el Horizonte era yama
el dios de la muerte que había ido a
llevarse el alma de satian al más allá
pero sabitri aún no se daba por vencida
siguió al Dios durante horas bajo el
calor extremo yama le gritó a la
princesa que lo dejara en paz pero
aunque sus pies sangrar y su garganta
ardiera
savitri no
volvería eventualmente yama se detuvo le
concedería un deseo como premio a su
persistencia pero no podía pedir la vida
de su
esposo sin pensarlo dos veces sabitri le
pidió que devolviera la vista a su
suegro el deseo fue cumplido y yama
siguió su camino pero seguía escuchando
los pasos de
sabitri exasperado El Dios le concedió
un segundo deseo esta vez ella pidió que
el reino de saavan fuera restituido y
otra vez el deseo fue cumplido y yama
comenzó el descenso a su reino
subterráneo pero al ver atrás le
impresionó ver a la desaliñada princesa
siguiéndolo Jamás había visto tal
devoción a los muertos y honró su
dedicación con un último
deseo sabitri deseaba ser madre de
muchos hijos el Dios se lo cumplió y se
despidió de ella pero la princesa
repitió el voto que había hecho un año
antes su destino estaba entrelazado con
el de saavan cómo podía tener muchos
hijos Si yama no le devolvía a su esposo
Al escuchar esa buena pregunta el Dios
se dio admitiendo la derrota con la
bendición y respeto de yama satian fue
devuelto a sabitri juntos caminaron de
vuelta a la tierra de los vivos Unidos
en un amor que ni siquiera la muerte
podía
destruir Gracias por mirar t ded en
español si le gustó este video haga clic
en suscribirse para no perderse
[Música]
ninguno